que le cyclisme avec paris roubaix cet
après-midi les pavés du nord
la reine des classiques sous le soleil
apparemment la poussière du côté des
différents secteurs les trois villes
d'arenberg mons-en-pévèle famars
reportage ce matin grégory naboulet et
david fossard c'est la tradition ici dès
l'aube à pied ou bien à vélo amateurs et
curieux viennent goûter aux pavés
d'arenberg leaf avait son petit cabossé
abîmée par le temps et le passage mais
il ne laisse personne insensible
ça s'est mal aux fesses beaucoup de
secousses ont fait secouer dans tous les
sens à force de faire des pavés on a des
ampoules facilement un passage mythique
tout coureur qui n'a pas fait de la
tranchée d'arenberg à gauche je crois
que il lui manque quelque chose dans son
palmarès
la tranchée d'arenberg symbole du paris
roubaix une course exigeante où tout
écart se paye cher cette année les
coureurs doivent donc t 51 km de
secteurs pavés aremberg dans le temps
les tranchées servait à acheminer le
bois de la forêt vers la mine
aujourd'hui les supporters ont remplacé
les mineurs et les camping-cars ont élu
domicile ici on vient de toute l'europe
italie suisse angleterre pays bas et
bien sûr de belgique
le suisse fabian cancellara vainqueur
l'an dernier et le grand favori d'une
course qui échappe aux français depuis
14 ans maintenant un grand soleil près
de 25 degrés de quoi bien sûr faire le
bonheur des supporters ils seront des
milliers cet après midi sur le bord des
pavés mais pas forcément celui des
coureurs l'enfer du nord sera un enfer
de chaleur et de poussières aujourd'hui
on les attend ici aremberg dans une
heure maintenant